Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Do you see what episode it is today?
It's 75!
My episode 75!
Thank you for joining us for our 75th episode!
BAU BAU!
I'm a little cold this morning.
You good.
BAU BAU.
Sometimes, you know, all you can do is just BAU it out.
BAU BAU!
You're good!
All you can do is just BAU it out, Ruffians.
Some days, you'll have mornings like that.
Where you just, you roll out of bed, but you're still a bit chilly.
The bones quite aren't warmed up high.
Someone needs stretches.
Don't we all need stretchy paws?
But more importantly, it's episode 75!
I remember it was just episode 50 the other day, and well, you know, things were a little bit rough, but Ruffians were really happy to be able to celebrate and have our episode 75 today with you!
Right around
Our 6 month anniversary!
It worked perfectly!
Math is crazy!
Right!
Well you know, FUWAMOCO Morning has now been around for 6 months!
But there might be some Ruffians who are joining us for the first time today!
I saw some of you!
I saw!
Well, to explain, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
BAU BAU!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you always say hashtag, hashtag, but do you remember what the hashtag is?
I'm concerned.
This is a very good question.
But you know, after a bit of stretches, maybe you're feeling a bit more warmed up now.
I'm feeling a bit warmed up.
Hopefully you are as well, Ruffians.
But remember, sometimes you just gotta BAU it out.
BAU it out hard.
Well, this is another case of BAUing it out.
Well...
You know, there was another Pero Sighting.
Just BAU it out.
BAU it out.
Well, what did Pero do this time?
Huh?
What did he do?
He's always up to something.
Alright.
Well, the last time you know, picking up duck watching, bird watching is the hardest.
That was very nice.
Very nice.
How about this time?
This time!
Oh!
Is this the continuation of the hobby?
The continuation?
First, you know, watching the dogs from a nice distance?
So many pigeons!
Yeah!
But, but, but!
You're not scared of them!
You're so close!
Look at the one in the right!
Right there, he's like, I'm gonna get you!
Right?
He's gonna eat your shoes!
FUWAMOCO, you know, we just, we just get scared of pigeons!
We try to walk as far away as possible from them because, you know, Ruffians are just so unpredictable!
You know?
I don't know, maybe that's why Pero's trying to fit in with them.
I don't know, they're kind of nasty too, huh?
Nasty like, you know, because Pero's nasty, but it's not like we strongly dislike pigeons, but it's just, you know, they suddenly, they always like to fly up and surprise you when you're not expecting it.
No, it's not very nice.
It's not nice.
I don't want to be surprised.
I don't want it to bump into me or get caught in the fluff.
Land on me.
Not that cute.
I'm not expecting that.
But you know, the cluing is really cute.
You know, it's kind of like cats purring.
Right.
All right.
If only Pero purred, maybe.
We like him a bit more, huh?
I think so.
Well, hopefully Pero didn't walk away from that group of pigeons with unsuspecting bird in his tummy.
But you never know!
You never know.
Yeah, you know, he's used to leftovers and
Well... I wouldn't be surprised.
Yeah.
It could happen.
BAU BAU!
You feel like Pero may be a bird watcher?
I feel like that too, but now I'm starting to think that maybe this hobby wasn't what we kind of were thinking it was.
Maybe it's more like a... Sinister.
A buffet.
Maybe like a buffet, a sinister buffet.
Yeah.
Wow!
Ruffians.
You heard yesterday.
For sure, definitely.
I mean, I just kind of mentioned it.
But!
It's now officially been six months since all of Adam and Damien!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Can you believe it?
Oh my goodness.
We can't at all.
No.
We just feel so, so thankful.
You know, so incredibly thankful to have you here supporting us and all of Advent for these past six months.
You know, it really means everything to us.
I know!
We've had so much fun!
Lots of laughs and have created so many things together with you Ruffians.
So really, thank you!
Thank you!
It's been a really wonderful six months, but you know what to celebrate this time!
We have this!
Yeah, we had a very silly collab stream all with Albert when we played some more Gliding Fall, but we also announced some special half-year celebration merch as well!
First, we have a very cool tapestry featuring all of Albert with this design here.
And you know, we also even have cooler metal wanted keychains of each of us.
Wanted keychains.
In case you heard something different like I did.
What did I say?
I said wanted.
I would want you to feel like you want to get the wanted keychain.
Wait!
We're not hololive Wanted, okay?
No.
Yeah.
But, we hope that you'll pick them up from the official hololive store and continue to love Advent as much as you have for these past six months.
But, you confused the Ruffians.
What?
Ruffians!
It's been six months, why are you still confused?
Understandable!
Understandable.
You're not confused.
I'm sorry.
I misunderstood how you felt.
It's a tradition.
Well... In case you're interested!
Yeah!
You can pre-order the half-year celebration merchandise up until the beginning of March.
So you still have some time.
You still have time.
Maybe...
You know, things are a little bit rougher than you expected.
I didn't want to wait.
It's okay!
You have a bit of time.
Yeah.
But you know, it's been six months.
You know, we've been doing a bit of reflection.
More than usual recently, because we reflect a lot.
But, you know, it's been six months.
I know.
It's been a long time, but a short time.
And, you know, we're truly excited for everything coming up!
And just how much we feel that Advent's been fun together.
Yeah.
We're so thankful to be a part of Advent and surrounded by so much talented girls.
Right!
Such a nice, nice Advent!
Nice.
Nice Advent.
We're gonna continue to use all our energy we have and fight just as hard as it took for us to get out of this cell to do even more amazing things in hololive.
Don't miss it, okay?
BAU BAU!
Six months before you know it, it'll be another six months and we'll be at our one year anniversary.
That's crazy.
Don't think, just jam!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, yesterday was quite a big day.
Not just because it was Advent's half anniversary, but also because IRyS-senpai, well, she revealed a brand new outfit!
BAU BAU!
Did you get a chance to take a look, Ruffians?
If you didn't look, no!
Look!
But now you know!
IRyS-senpai has this really super cute gamer cyber inspired outfit with such a cool colorful jacket and some awesome shoes that are not pictured but they're awesome!
Believe us, they're awesome!
It can even be dressed down into a really pretty and proper safe outfit as well too!
And the glasses!
And the straight down breeches!
They're really cute!
I love it.
You know, especially the swirly glasses too.
Yeah, IRyS-senpai's swirly glasses.
It's so cute, huh?
It's so multifunctional.
We're really looking forward to seeing IRyS-senpai use this outfit lots and lots for sure in the future, right?
Right?
It's so cute!
Very cute!
Glasses!
Cute.
I think that, you know, more of us should have glasses.
Why not?
Well, these Demon Dogs have pretty good eyesight, you know, so... What do you think, Ruffians?
Glasses.
No.
No!
No, no, no.
Maybe?
Ruffians, what's wrong with glasses?
I didn't know.
We like glasses.
I didn't know you don't like these, Ruffians.
I guess that's concerning, huh?
Wow.
A big congratulations on the new outfit to IRyS-senpai!
I like IRyS-senpai's glasses!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
So exciting!
Very cute.
Very very cute.
Ruffians, actually, we have to say that we're sorry because we have yet another apology to make.
Another.
Yeah.
So many apologies this week, Moco-chan.
It's only Wednesday.
Right.
We shouldn't have to apologize after our birthday.
Well, you see,
We made a mistake today.
One that we've never made before.
Never ever.
Maybe it was because we were too excited.
Or maybe because we were too sleepy.
Or should I say that we were too sleepy.
Sleepy.
Ah well.
You know, that's because during our watch-along for Watame-senpai's second solo concert, Watame Night Fever, that just happened just a few hours ago.
Well, we made a mistake.
We did.
Yeah.
Do you know what it was?
We completely forgot to introduce ourselves, Ruffians!
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
You know, we must've just gotten wrapped up in the BAU BAU DO DO DO DOI!
Right.
And we were just too focused on thinking what the concert would be like and I guess, you know, we forgot.
Yeah.
So, worst way that any Ruffians came in and got confused.
Oh no.
You know.
Who are these Demon Dogs?
Who's Fuwawa?
Who's Mococo?
I don't know, they didn't introduce themselves.
Right.
It's only natural that you will be confused.
You know, we didn't properly introduce ourselves.
So, we'll make sure that from now on, we'll do our jobs as professionals!
And introduce ourselves to you every single time so there's no confusion!
Let's take this moment to
Introduce ourselves again.
One more time!
Just in case there's some Ruffians who, you know, still aren't sure.
And maybe feel a bit awkward asking.
Yeah, we wouldn't want them to feel awkward.
Good idea.
Okay, Ruffians.
I'm not a chihuahua!
I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa!
I'm Mococo!
Together we're FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Got it.
No more awkward feelings.
No confusion.
Just some professional puppies right here.
Right here.
That's us!
BAU BAU!
Now you recognize us?
Good!
Good, see?
Happy to hear it.
It was important to apologize about something of that magnitude.
You know it's good to apologize.
Yeah.
But, Ruffians, you know, FUWAMOCO, we always are keeping our eyes open, our paws on the post, ears to the...
To the rocks?
Sure!
But recently, you know, we've been seeing some mumblings, maybe some mutterings, you know, of those who are confused not just about who's Fuwawa, who's Mococo, but you know, other things.
You know, same thing like, I thought FUWAMOCO were twins!
Why are they on different days?
So they weren't twins after all, huh?
Yeah.
Huh?
Well!
Just because our birthdays are on different days doesn't make us any less twins.
Yeah.
Got it.
We're identical twins, Demon Guard Dogs.
Thank you!
As you may know, Fuwawa's birthday is on February 1st.
Yeah!
And mine is February 2nd.
And you know, this is because it was
The Blessing of the Moon!
I don't think FUWAMOCO wants us to talk too much more about things.
She did her best!
Yeah, and I was born on the first, and then Moco-chan, you were born on the second.
Yeah!
It's just how things work out, you know?
Yeah.
Sometimes important things can take a while, so it's not that simple.
It's a little bit of a delicate topic.
That's true.
Yeah.
You know, all it means is, you know... MY CELEBRATION!
Yeah!
Double the fun time!
Double!
Okay.
But, technically, maybe it's kind of triple though.
Because we have a birthday countdown party tonight, and then my solo birthday party, and then Moco-chan's solo birthday party too!
Hai!
Lots and lots and lots of fun!
Not just double, maybe triple.
We really hope that you know you'll be there to celebrate with us.
Our first ever birthday as hololive members!
The first time is only ever once, so let's have lots of fun.
Uh-huh.
You know, and remember... We're still twins, even if our birthdays are on different days.
Even if.
Got it.
No questions.
We explained to you.
Yeah, you don't need to embarrass Mama Puppy more than... Well... How about Pero?
This is our birthday to tell you!
Our birthdays!
Don't ask about Pero!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, it's the middle of the week, our birthday week.
And you know, even though there's exciting things coming up.
Well, Ruffians, how are you feeling today?
Maybe a little cold?
A little cold, need some stretches.
Maybe some stretches for the heart.
Moco-chan, do you have anything to help with that?
Maybe.
Ruffians!
How are you feeling today?
Need some heart stretches?
Well, first off, do you know what today is?
Do you know what today is?
Wednesday.
Yeah!
Today is a Wednesday!
Which means that this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear from me, straight from the Mococo!
Good morning!
I see you there.
You're still a bit sleepy, aren't you, huh?
Well, that's okay!
It's time to get up and get going.
But don't rush yourself too much if you aren't feeling physically up to it, okay?
It's important to listen to what your body is saying, so... You know, if you're feeling strong, you're feeling strong!
But sometimes, you're not.
It changes every day.
You know, you've been doing your best!
And sometimes, your best will be more!
And some days it'll be less!
But one thing doesn't change, you know.
And that is, that your best is your best.
It doesn't have to be the same output every day.
You know?
You've been working hard and you should be proud of all that effort, okay?
Got it!
Now, today,
I actually have a very important message for you as well.
So, please listen closely, okay?
Biboo Biboo, let down your long, long, rock-like hair.
But if it falls onto me, I will be in my grave earlier than... your mom.
Loves you very much!
You're doing amazing, beautiful!
Never give up!
Ganbatte de!
This was Mococo Pup Talk!
BAU BAU!
That was a weird pup talk, huh?
I like the part where you mention the Ruffians' mom.
That was pretty nice.
Inspiring.
Thank you, Moco-chan.
You're welcome.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's see who our Doggie of the Day is today!
We have De-den!
Today's Doggie of the Day is Milo!
What a puppy!
Right?
Look at those ears!
Yeah, he hasn't grown into them at all.
I like his eyebrows.
His eyebrows!
Oh, I know, but it looks like he has a case of the helicopter tail.
Yeah.
Cute!
And he's going through the chew on the sofa phase too.
That happens.
I remember that.
Actually, this photo of Milo is from about a month ago.
Can you imagine how big he is now?
He's probably as big as two Milos now.
Probably.
Right.
How do you think Milo BAU BAU-es?
Milo now, of today, the two times the size Milo.
I think it still sounds like
Really?
That's Milo of today, Moco-chan.
Of today?
You sure?
I think his barker hasn't really grown.
That's okay.
You sure?
Maybe the Ruffians can get a more accurate Milo.
A rubber duck.
He is a puppy.
He's Milo.
Not a duck.
No.
Got it.
You know, Milo is a very cute puppy who does all the puppy things.
All of them.
Yeah, but just make sure that his tail doesn't fly away if he gets too happy, okay?
You have to keep him grounded, okay?
He's not a duck.
He can't fly.
Actually, you know, naturally as he gets bigger, that helicopter tail, it might slow down.
But I'll tell you one thing.
That same amount of crazy happiness will continue to be in his heart whenever he sees you!
No matter how big he is!
It won't change.
BAU BAU!
Very cute!
And for today I rate on a rock, we have De-den!
Look at that Fuwawa blue sky!
Very very FUWAWA Blue High!
Yeah, it looks like such a nice morning run.
Just a wonderful way to start off your day, right?
We're glad that you know you're enjoying some time off.
I'm all for our birthday!
Thank you!
We're really looking forward to celebrating our birthdays together with you!
BAU BAU!
It's so pretty.
It really makes you want to go for a nice run, right?
Perfect weather.
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I have a question.
When you played games together as puppies, did you ever fight over who got to be Player 1 and who had to be Player 2?
Or did you just go with the classic, the older sibling is always Player 1?
BAU BAU!
It's a good question.
Why?
I don't think we really ever fought over it.
Maybe it just sort of came down to feeling.
Yeah.
I don't really particularly remember being Player 1 or Moco-chan being Player 2.
No!
Huh?
Yeah, but, you know, as we started to get older, there became a Moco-chan where you'd be the main player, and where I would kind of help, so... Yeah, it just kind of worked out like that naturally.
Yeah.
No fighting.
Just having fun.
Yeah.
And you know, that's how things are still to this day, you know?
Help.
Help!
No yelling.
I've been training for many years in the way of help.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the questions!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for always being a very important part of our FUWAMOCO Mornings.
Remember, we're still always looking for your doggy of the days, your questions, Pero Sightings, if you happen to see Pero, and the walks that you've been going on too.
Please let us know!
And also if you have any FUWAMOCO scoops, please report your journalism to us using the hashtag FWMCSCOOP too.
Thank you so much everyone!
BAU BAU!
Wow, our next team, we have De-den!
It's almost our birthday!
You know tonight, we have our birthday countdown!
But tomorrow is Fuwawa's big day!
And the day after that is Moco-chan's big day!
So, you know, we hope that you'll join us tonight a bit later than our usual streaming time.
A bit.
A bit later, yeah.
And then that way, you know, we can spend the first moments of our birthdays together with you!
BAU BAU!
And for our schedule!
On Thursday, and then on Friday, that's when our birthday celebrations are going to happen!
Yeah!
On our birthday days.
Yeah, it makes sense.
But, you know, rather than, you know, the usual FUWAMOCO together, it'll give us a little bit more time to be able to express ourselves individually and sing a number of our favorite songs for you just from us.
Individually!
Well, we have a bunch of things that we want to do together and share with you.
So we hope that you'll be there for both of our birthday karaoke parties, okay?
BAU BAU!
It happens, okay, Ruffians?
It happens!
Get used to it!
That's the second time we've synced on the word individual, huh?
I think so.
Hello Ruffians!
We want to thank you for joining us today for Episode 75 of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Also, you know, it's 6 months anniversary of Advent's FUWAMOCO's debut!
FUWAMOCO Morning, Isabel!
It's been an eventful time!
Eventful time.
But thank you for always being a big part of everything we do.
And also, thank you for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Nick29!
BAU BAU!
Chocolate seal.
Hungary.
BAU BAU!
Leaf Hut.
Meadwire.
BAU BAU!
Swampykins.
Savage Brands.
BAU BAU!
B12.
Velvet.
BAU BAU!
Nomolo.
Taru Taru!
BAU BAU!
Twitch!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!